hello welcome back to new rockstars
debrief everyone I'm Eric vas joining me
today are Sam basher howdy ho neighbor
Reno and Maude Garrett you know that
Ned's wife is called Maude Oh may the
force be with you yes guys today is a
huge day in all things nerd we got a
release of a trailer of Star Wars
Episode nine the rise of Skywalker at
Star Wars Celebration in Chicago we
learned the title which I just said a
bunch of stuff come out about that also
is a huge week for like just general
Marvel Star Wars Disney news because we
learned about it with Disney plus new
streaming service it's gonna change the
game in all kinds of ways we also are
getting ourselves super hyped for Game
of Thrones final season and are as we re
watch the writers gave us an indication
of which episodes are essential and
which ones apparently aren't great
already that we're doing it now because
yeah great thanks guys it was too much
my life well here's your friendly weekly
reminder that this show is also
available as a podcast you can find us
on Apple podcasts that Millea app or
wherever you get your podcasts and don't
forget to subscribe to the Westeros
weekly feed so you're ready for all of
our content dropping over the first
episode which is coming out in a couple
days did you get up to in the list
because that was rising real fast number
eight in TV and film in certain subsets
were a real big deal folks well this is
exciting time and thank you all for
subscribing in it you know shared around
let's let's get us up to number one but
let's get started with our lead story
okay so that was big deal
we got our epic first trailer for Star
Wars Episode nine the rise of Skywalker
we got a lot to say about this we saw a
badass move by Rey literally sky walkin
and then there's shots of all the old
gang kylo Ren and Po and also Lando is
back folks
Billy Dee Williams classic last movie
there's a new droid named do who looks
awesome road con years oh yeah and then
we also have a shot of the late great
Carrie Fisher who they're somehow
working into this film and voiceover by
Mark Hamill Luke Skywalker's probably
going to play some role in the plot I
we're currently mid production on the
breakdown I know a lot of you guys been
tweeting me about that that will come
out later this weekend probably Sunday
but I want to know what you guys thought
we just watch a trailer before we
started taping and I want to know like
first reactions how did you guys feel
while you're watching them man their
trailer houses know they know how to get
me it's almost not fair to use John
Williams I know he scores this it's
almost not fair though it's like it's
like seeing for me like Richard Jenkins
play a dad in a movie or if Michael
Caine's in anything I'm just like my
cold guy and I are I'm already on board
so as soon as John Williams kicked and
I'm like oh wait this is this is what
dreams are this feels very much like
Episode seven you can tell the JJ's back
he's got the reins again and he's
charging hard and fast I also really
like that this is Ray's story again I
think the worst thing I actually really
liked the last shadow but the worst
thing that they did was split up ray and
John burgers character Finn
they have such amazing chemistry they
love each other to death and it's like
why would you not sort of like go with
that instead of splitting it up and like
then I interviewed them they was super
bummed that they weren't spending time
on set together you know and it's like
you can't make that chemistry up you got
to harness that and so that's kind of
like the only thing that kind of was
heartbreaking this is her story she's
gonna have her Jedi Knight moment I
noticed the biggest thing though is that
the last Jedi is heavily read this is
all blue Oh like a color the blue saber
is she gonna have her Green saber moment
which is what Luke had in returning the
jib yeah it's like poetry it rhymes
I liked the lack of kylo Ren as well oh
but don't worry gang cuz that helmet
that we definitely crushed into oblivion
in the second movie is being rebuilt and
it's got new flare on it he had it
flames to the side of everyone knows you
had some reds or something oh yeah
that's why that speeder that plane don't
correct me on what that is that ship
right there had some red on the front
Sam it's cool that you bring that up
because it does feel like mod and you
were addressing this to that a lot of
the things in this trailer feel like
it's fixing or mending or repairing
things that were
broken in the last Jedi both literally
and metaphorically I don't have another
example for you right now snark was a
joke
and now we've got Sidious back right and
it's I don't think it's gonna be
Palpatine I don't think Palpatine can
come back oh I think this is purely
gonna be Sidious here weren't they the
same aren't they say but he played both
characters like really convincingly one
of them was a politician that was well
respected and then Sidious was the Sith
Lord so it's like he was manipulating as
the one person two very distinct
different things with everyone not
knowing it was the same person
hence the hood you know um so I think
he's gonna come back who knows how
that's going to play but I were feeling
he's gonna be training kylo and so he's
gonna step into Stokes shoes he did he
had golden slippers I hope it's not
Palpatine or Sidious it's just I get
like I liked I'll tell you I liked in
last should I at least it they were
trying to do new things and force
awakens for me was like member all old
things and I was like I don't want I
don't want to keep looking at the old
things I want to see new things now
that's saying last job I worked all the
way through I enjoyed it enough but I
did like them at least trying something
different
refreshing feel you see though you see
the deaths are and you like that's
awesome cuz that's like a moon crashing
onto a plane yeah it's like it's it's
interesting that's really cool but it is
the same it's the same thing and we're
literally scrout scavenging through the
bones of things from the past to find
something that we can talk about I I
mean the whole digging through the bones
of the past to make new stories is
essentially our whole business model
here at new roxxor took the Pikachu
bones of the past like a movie bones of
the past those are literal bones
somewhere in a box in my attic in my
hometown that's I I hear what you're
saying I hate to break your heart it is
gonna be Palpatine slash cities because
MacDiarmid went on the stage at
celebration and he's such a formidable
amazing villain he's frightening he's so
clever he's five steps ahead of
everything he is he's not an illusion in
this way where it's like Snoke
we never got answers from that we just
didn't understand what the point or
purpose of that is an entity was
having the backstory in history a
Sidious created Vader so successfully
this was a guy who literally was on the
path of righteousness and he wished
flipped him off super hard and then and
got a like what do you call him my first
commander what is he he's puppet
basically oh yeah so it's the same guy
from all three of the trilogy's now
that's the bad guy and the prequels yeah
yeah sorry that's what I mean like
prequels what you wondering why he's
back there he makes one part of Revenge
of the Sith very much stand out and the
biggest point and purpose of it was did
you hear the story of Darth Plagueis
and Darth Plagueis was a Sith Lord who
learnt to basically never die mm-hmm so
the fact that Sidious should be dead and
Maul should have been dead and mauls
back it's because there's an entity like
a power like we're conducting the force
where you can actually become alive
again hey I will say this trailer
totally got me though I'm gonna buy it
again and I'm totally sold on this I
just I hope I just as long as the magic
is there from Star Wars that everyone is
attracted to it's in the movie that I'm
gonna be happy yeah great I just want I
think my biggest concern is if JJ gets
to over correctional you know like I
don't want it to be too much of a all
the things you were mad about like don't
respond to knee-jerk lead to the fans
just like tell the story that you always
want to tell and hopefully that he will
and what was great about his voice and
his presence as a behind the lens of the
force awakens will be back again in this
one it feels like an improv game where
someone doesn't know how to do improv
it's like I'm scary gonna get whiplash
from this where it's like what's
happening over you know back again okay
yeah well so this movie's being directed
by JJ Abrams this week we actually
learned that he almost turned it down
and it was until the last Jedi came out
where he's like you know what I think I
will make it back up but I think let's
talk about the title of this right the
rise of Skywalker and it inspires a lot
of questions yes Sidious line isn't it
rise da da da yeah
is it cyclical in that way is Amit to be
a reflection of that Luke did die at the
end of the last Jedi so what does that
mean will
you know lei is probably they're gonna
establish how she died presumably in the
opening act to this movie does this mean
that too soon either one of them will
rise in some other way is it referring
to Ben kylo Ren and his rise back into
the skywalker can we please get the
Knights of Ren I would like that nice to
see that JJ laid the foundations for
we're just gonna revisit that maybe it
sounds so cool so much better yeah
what's but what's more intimidating than
one guy even like seven other guys I
like the idea well I mean I enjoy the
title it doesn't personally mean too
much to me I like the idea of someone
rising from the ashes you got a tease of
that if you're talking about like the
Sidious storyline of him coming back in
some way whatever that is that's cool
the rise of like you know what Rey's
parentage is excused I was about to say
something that is incorrect now that we
know but also the idea of like either I
don't know about Kyle getting a
Redemption Redemption arc but something
about him changing and leading to the
future of what that means for other
people in this galaxy I don't know
there's there's a few different ways you
could go about it I I would like to see
some force ghosts in this I'll pay you
well it's alliteration guys the third
movie and every one of the installations
of the trilogy's the The Revenge of the
Sith and then it's Return of the Jedi
and now it's rise of Scott Walker yeah
and is there had to be our thinking in
that line of thinking is it possible
there may be a connection between Sith
Jedi and Skywalker as well like not just
like Lou they're all Star Wars things
but in the way that the Sith were a
category of people the Jedi were a
category of people could Skywalker be
more generally used rather than just a
name or a common surname in the Star
Wars universe as someone who's a new
kind of force practitioner when it's new
generation we select about the Jedi
probably not you know you're saying that
the Skywalker is the only Jedi out there
and it becomes a new entity I don't
think they're gonna go great Jedi which
is neither right I think they're they'll
do some version of that that might be
inspired by the idea of gray Jedi and
legends or whatever you want to call it
hey you the I'm talking about like what
if we have like a lowercase s Skywalker
in the way that you know Jesus Christ
inspired a movement of
Christian's could the Skywalker word be
generalized for people who are neither
Jedi nor Sethe because that order has
died out
maybe now even one world I think walk
the line between the light and the dark
yeah the way that Luke kind of yeah in
that way we kind of build on some of the
themes of the last Jedi which I thought
one of the best things was the
description of the force is neither
light nor dark it's just about the
balance and hopefully that will persist
into the rise of Skywalker I think that
was the best edition at the last Jedi
made too though all the Star Wars films
it's very nuanced explanation of the
force and I don't want JJ just throw
that by the wayside no that was one of
the coolest moments for me like I guess
I missed every other explanation of the
force I heard him but like they didn't
stick with me this one did and I was I
actually really enjoyed it and the idea
that like Rey they kind of established
that like she might not be bad but she
just might not be what the Jedi what the
Jedi is supposed to be there's a lot of
power and has no way to harness it and
didn't really have a mentor or trainer
so she's just a full of energy yeah
who's good at things right away very
short learning curve is a survivor
she was called her whole life she
literally had to scavenge to survive
yeah thank you
when we first saw her if she didn't find
that that thing inside the Bruin Star
Destroyer she would have starved and
died at the end of that day and we
wouldn't have had this new trilogy she's
a survivor well let us know what you
guys think about this trailer again
we're gonna be talking about this a lot
I got a better look so freakin hot cocoa
move on he is Nathan Drake so much so
bad I want it I want it now I'm going
full of Arica I want it I know they
threw out maybe Tom Holland playing
Nathan Drake don't do that do Oscar
Isaac please
so bad please do that good I want it so
bad cone unicycle it looks amazing
well yeah comment down below keep an eye
out for the breakdown I dig so hard
in it but let's move on to our trivia
question oh yeah trivia question guess
what gang we got a surprise here cash
for a second so last week the gang from
new rock stars made their way over to
darkest timeline so it'll show the eric
puts on and lovely attending melissa
ashley good yes she made this beautiful
box let's take a look at that look at
those laws
I bet man you got Mickey Mouse you have
an Avengers you have different oh it's
beautiful and on top of trivia and
questions oh and get a little Rick and
Morningside Melissa you made an amazing
contribution to the new rock stars
debrief set we appreciate it we're gonna
be using it from now on doing our well
sure your question and so we have a box
or punishment box from Travis and our
question box will be cherish so yes yes
well buckle up I got you guys some
answer cards here it goes there's one
and there's a second one and a third one
here's a trivia question what was the
working title for Star Wars Episode two
attack of the clones Elroy let's go and
grab those pants got your answers whoo
where's it going it's going securely
back into the trivia box Melissa again
beautiful box man we have a new trivia
punishment we won't tell you yet what it
is we got to stick around to the end of
this episode to find out the boys took
at least three times as long as I did
for this answer so let's see how their
sting well hey what do you mean we all
took an immediate amount of time because
this was edited out wasn't it wasn't it
yeah well before we continue I just want
to take a quick second to thank audible
for sponsoring this video slash podcast
episode audible has an insane selection
of audio books including a lot of Star
Wars content including the aftermath
trilogy it's awesome if you want more
Star Wars but you know aren't into the
idea of sitting down and using your eyes
to read a book you can consider digging
into the Star Wars catalog on audible
you can learn more about your favorite
Star Wars characters in the histories of
where they came from and where they're
going while you're at the gym in a
waiting room cooking cleaning commuting
just like some of you guys are probably
doing right now with this episode you
can get started with a 30-day trial when
you go to audible.com slash rockstars
again that's audible.com slash rockstars
AUD ible comm /r Ock sta are s and it
could also text the word rockstars
to five hundred five hundred if you
prefer what's the one clue me staring
contest I may have actually blinked near
the end though but she looked like four
times okay pretty good that does
well this is a weekend of Game of
Thrones right and Maude what did you
hear from our own staff about I look
Game of Thrones writer Bryan cogman has
put together a handy list of which
episodes to re-watch best to prepare for
season 8 so obviously anything that
happens in one of these episodes is
really important so we're gonna run
through all of these episodes and see
what this suggests about the final
season which is starting this weekend
now he's only suggested 20 who just 21
of the episodes which is a few per
season that's only three episodes per
season that is mandatory viewing not
Alton which I watched all 17 episodes
and I didn't answer my phone for a while
there because I had a dedicated so
anyway he's - what the earth the 21
episodes we're gonna go through them
buckle up and if you're not a game of
Thrones fan skip all of this there's
gonna be spoilers we're gonna break it
down you ready
season 1 episode 1 winter is coming we
see the White Walkers Danny gets her
dragon eggs during her wedding to Khal
Drogo and Jen chieh me pushes bran out
of course is important that's the one
that establishes it all you can't reach
a series with at least watching the damn
pilot about the White Walkers really so
yeah it was double [ __ ] and season one
really does follow it's a great pilot
that's a really great great pilot but
not all shows have a good first episode
I remember when they were actual dogs on
the show yes CGI expensive messes we've
also got the kingsroad which is the next
one over season 1 episode 2 this is
where Jon gives a needle the sword he
asked about his mum as he's heading for
the wall with his dad and Ned goes I'll
tell you next time I see your son never
got to it then bran is attacked by the
assassin with the cat's paw dagger and I
guess it's nightmare fruit you know I
could see how the matically this one's
important right because you know for a
while we were trying to do an episode by
episode re-watch and that one's all
about like scapegoats
right and Game of Thrones is full of
characters who are punished for things
that they do not deserve to be punished
for including Ned Stark and and several
other characters so it was just curious
yeah so you killed the kid yeah
and hope we'll see if that ends up being
the case in the final season are we
going to see scapegoats are just
punishments and then after episode two
you can just skip all the way to Episode
nine beds where Jeff Jeffrey sorry Jeff
Jeffrey has been bedded we've also got
Mary masseur who does a best blood-magic
which is supposed to save Khal Drogo's
life ends up turning him into a
vegetable and John gets his sword
Longclaw which of course is Valyrian
steel we don't know that yet we don't
know the magic of it we don't kill White
Walkers shatter them into a little bit
at this point yeah and find out later
but at this point all we know is just
like a nice fancy sword with a wolf on
do you know though from this episode
that Jon Snow is not immune to fire or
yeah the birds and so yeah he's not pure
dragon unless I showed yeah maybe but
next we have fire in blood that's season
1 episode 10 the final episode you kind
of have to watch this one
arya dresses up as a boy and meets
Gendry we find out to be the bastard of
Robert Baratheon and then we have Danny
having a stillborn baby it's not too
much fun but then she emerges from a
fire with her three baby dragons which
is still for watch that episode about
three times now I haven't watched the
whole series three times but I've
watched that episode three times the
three dragons than a kid I mean it just
depends on what you're looking for
honestly at the end of the day kept my
eye on the back of a kid you can go
ahead and skip to season 2 episode 3
what his dead may never die with Arya
she starts her kill list which is a
healthy thing to start and she saves
jack n jackin rockin you guys directly
every time I say O God I thank you from
being burned alive by the Lannisters
joking huh gah is obviously basically
like a servant of the god of death oh
yes well so in Braavos which is a free
City and he teaches her how to become
the assassin further has a black one yes
it's a relationship throughout the
series against watch out but in that
episode and when she's he says give it
give him give him an a name and he'll
basically kill that person that's with
the cue list that's when she discovers
the power of
an ally in death it's an important
defendant moment in my recap and a heck
of a wig on that guy big fan of it also
we should focus on season 2 episode 6
the old gods and the new
this is where Jon meets Ygritte and OSHA
runs off with bran Rickon and Hodor why
is that important because I mean I feel
like that the only thing that really
happens in that episode is that when
they talk about no that's not in the
finale I think it's important for Jon's
journey because this is when he violates
his vows for the first time right he
when they have cake sex it's the first
time Jon really breaks off of his
trajectory to become his own man why
though because he sees what the Cresta
baby sacrifice is all about right which
the Night Watch sanctioned exactly yeah
people that I'm fighting for aren't
necessarily the good guys and so that's
what it yeah it also kind of gives you
the beginning of brands journey up north
you eventually get to the three eyed
Raven which we'll get to in just a
second but yes beginning of that also if
you want to know how much of a jerk Seon
is that's a good episode for that as
well oh yeah but then we move on to
season 2 episode 9 and this is the big
Blackwater episode the one we're tearing
these wildfires Landing from Stan's is
fleet just a huge pivotal episode for
the show is where we learned that they
are storing and building wildfire which
sets up the later explosion of the
steppe and manages - just tried to kill
Tyrion yeah an important moment where he
learns that he can't trust his own
family in his own soldiers and it's also
the first time I feel like we see
wildfire used like you just hear them
talk about it and it's even when I saw a
clip of the explosion watching the full
episode in the context of it still made
me kind of gasp below yeah yeah we all
thought that the King's Landing was
doomed and they even presented bonfires
like a crackpot invention but that
actually totally worked but then the
next important episode of co-occurring
to cogman is season 3 episode 3 that's
walk of punishment that's it so that
Gilly gives birth to her baby and the
episode of course where Jaime Lannister
gets his hand cut off by the goat a
genuine gasp from Sam that was a big
guess from me
yeah that one now did not see that
coming what so what so ever Bolton's
that's when I was immediately like Oh
Bolton's on an allied
but in this one why is it important
about Gilly with her baby watches does
this represent knowing that this baby
was supposed to be sacrificed to the
night king right
does that make Gilly and Sam an
additional target for the night king is
he gonna go after that baby down in the
crypts of King Winterfell right now is
that where he's headed next is that one
part of his goals you should go check
out another video we did a last episode
of Westeros weekly where we kind of
speculate what then that Kings plan
could be and that could be bring the
night oh is it to bring winter won't
ever know well now we'll never know and
the next episode is the following one
season 3 episode 4 and now his watch has
ended that's where the one where Varys
tells Tyrion about the sorcerer that
captured him a wizard in the box that
the show never brought up again well I
thought they did to bring it up one more
time when he told the similar story to
Daenerys Targaryen didn't he did he have
a story once in my broken dad's being
gone okay yes well he's always talked
about like he's worried about the kids
of the realm and he doesn't want kids
being tortured yet he tortures awit sir
wizard in a box for the guy's entire
life despite this guy being a monster
whatever this is all said we made the
prophecy that the wizard said though I
never knew what that was Oh parts in the
fire and he heard a voice and some
people thought that it could be the Lord
of Light sacrifice blood
hmm perhaps we also meet beric
Dondarrion and Daenerys tells the
unsullied to kill this is a big power
treatment a stupor moment for her where
she waits for a full army at her
disposal it's pretty dang cool but then
what's the next episode this is I guess
the one right after that he's by fire
which is season 3 episode 5 where Jamie
tells bran about killing the Mad King so
you understand why is called the
Kingslayer and we see beric Dondarrion
being brought back to life I believe
this is for the sixth time yeah that's a
resurrection as a power the Lord of
Light yeah when you actually see you met
I mean show the dragons but when you see
magic and the effect that it has also
like seeing Brienne and Jaime together
so I don't I definitely recommend this
yeah they're pretty good together yeah
when we got the rains of castamere which
is solution 3 episode 9 red wedding
yep I see you I'm getting stabbed
repeatedly yeah yeah can't skip that one
never make you say it's if you see that
once your eyes watch the second time you
only need to see it once yeah never got
the loads of gods and men which is
season 4 episodes see
Yara tries and fails to rescue spean
which was the most anti climactic moment
in an entire season Tyrion gives his
iconic speech about being a dwarf and
demands a trial by combat which yes
insert dawn interesting but after that
we have the mountain in the Viper that
season 4 episode 8 in the trial by
combat with the mountain whose smushes
toll you think full head taller there
then it right and everyone again yeah we
have a squish and Oberyn Martell's face
it looks like I don't know there's a lot
of equations like watermelon falling on
the back of a truck
lot of vegetables or fruit imagery that
comes to my head but also after that we
have the children that season 4 episode
10 Breanna and the Hound fight one of my
favorite scenes from the entire show and
we also have Qyburn who starts
frankensteining the mountain for the
first time and bran meets the three-eyed
raven so that's probably the biggest
part of that episode right like the
existence of the the children of the
forest and the three-eyed Raven and the
forest that created the night king right
why don't the first men why yeah yeah
it's worth mentioning why the mountain
still there like that's a good episode
for that where it's like why is that why
this man looks so sick underneath that
he'll what is dead may never die
ultimate forms of resurrection that's
it's yet another form of someone kind of
dying but being brought back so you have
the Lord of Light doing it you've got
weed like alchemy and then you have the
undead and arguably the drowned God even
though that's just in their belief they
believe that someone around all the way
and dies that's how they baptize don't
you have to cough up the water and come
back and that's so there's kind of a
resurrection there at least according to
their beliefs yeah you buy it and then
finally we got hardhome not finally I
just this is my last time I talked about
hardhome Season 5 episode 8 Danny talks
about breaking the wheel and John and
company lose the fight at hardhome and
learn the night king can reanimate the
dead in one of the coolest shots it's
you're screwed it was like a genuine
horror movie scene and also you learned
so much about the mechanics of the magic
when it comes to night walkers and what
can what can kill them what can hurt
them also what their capabilities are
because everything else has been like
hinted at but also
see how fragile the wildlings are I mean
this whole time you've learnt them is
like you know some of the mechana bulls
or thins are cannibals you know they're
so hard and angry and then you've got
this woman who's a mother and she cannot
kill these children whites they're
children that have been turned Undead
children and that's what kills her and
it's just like oh this is so really the
threats real on an emotional level of
physical level yeah it was such a cool
thing to see happen on the show cuz like
book readers knew of hardhome it's
something that happens away we don't
have a point of view chapter of hardhome
so knowing that john was going to
hardhome in that and that season ever
was like oh my god this is the only step
aside from season five that cogman
considered worth re-watching which i
think is interesting not even the final
episode where john gets you know really
yeah but then we jump ahead to season
six in fact we skip all of John snows
mutiny and his resurrection is he's
saying this is not important which I
it's kind of weird because it could be
very important noting as well that by
the end of season five that's when it
goes off books that's when the books end
so this is all speculation that there so
and one of the things that they created
new to the show is the episode of the
door and that's the episode where brand
goes back in time he learns about the
origin of the White Walkers he himself
becomes a three-eyed Raven when the Max
von Sydow version dies and then Hodor
dies by Stephen bran with a hole the
door Hodor reveal of time travel in the
world of Game of Thrones there's also
some stuff about not the first time that
we've seen someone's entire life purpose
to aid Briggs
he's got a weird reveal on the show Jake
yeah he knew that he was gonna die doing
it but that's what he had to do Hodor
they screwed with his mind to make him
simple because he's one job was to carry
him and if he actually had his own life
it would go against his number one put
that's just too hard yeah it's a weird
thing it's interesting he tells it wants
us to see that even though it's such a
big moment on the show will we see time
travel again part of me hopes not
because it's a different show than what
I think Game of Thrones is and should be
I wish I umbrella or Academy backed away
from that yes yeah that's another that's
another segment another episode of
course the Battle of the bastards season
6 episode 9 that's the battle by John in
the
northern friends to take back Winterfell
from the Bolton's zip so that ends with
say it's a feeding Ramsay Bolton oh and
the biggest villains on the show his
dogs such a great moment
what a well episode erected episode both
this and hardhome were directed by
Miguel Capote Nick who's directing two
of the episodes in season 8 so maybe
that's why he wants to see like these
grand epic battle scenes where suppose
neck is really at his best work and then
the winds of winter that season six
episode 10 the finale of scene six
that's where Aria kills Walder Frey with
the Frey pie what a great moment that
was there somebody reveals this episode
that's where Danny finally set sail for
Westeros brand confirms the R plus L
equals J Theory John's actual mother is
Lyanna stark and then we see the vision
of a tower of joy this missed historical
event that book readers and show fans
have been speculating about and of
course this is the episode where Cersei
blows up the great Sept of Baelor and
it's such a crazy huge moment that's
where she's just lost it yeah the mad
Queen arises in that episode it was
we're watching it knowing what was going
to happen I still didn't know that was
gonna happen in that scene I didn't I
didn't know I was like oh oh oh no it
felt like a runaway train when you think
about it that is that is her completing
the self-fulfilling prophecy with Maggy
the Frog where it's like your three
children will all die you know and you
know they're not your your husband's
children they are your children I've got
gold of crown but like that's that
sealed the deal where it was like yeah
you're done it's over for you so you
know the Queen's Justice which is season
7 episode 3 this is when John and Danny
mate and the sexual tension is arrived
bran and Sansa reunite and brands just
like I don't know full-blown Beatle at
this stage Melisandre gives Varys her
prediction that they're gonna both die
in Westeros and Delana Tyrell dies in
the best way ever I want you to I'm
gonna butcher a quote I can't do a quote
that's like my never wanted to note with
me why can I do that I'm not the kind of
person that would literally say dairy
was a poor decision like I cannot quote
anything probably yes it oh I mean that
must be because that's the episode where
Jon and Daenerys meet and they have this
great scene and that's why it's
important to the first watch good
otherwise it's cute oh they're cute
Daario naharis is just like no worries
I'm looking over the entire east for you
because I'm in love with you while you
go find a husband spoils of war season 7
episode 4 aya returns to
to fill Littlefinger gives Brad the
cat's paw dagger which ends up being I
feel irrelevant Danny and her dragon
kicks ass in the loot train battle
I'm so cool when Jamie's charging
towards the dragon to Danny and you're
like what are you doing and then all of
a sudden he's like on the shoreline and
then he drops like 82 feet into the
ground oh yeah I'm just so satisfying to
see a Lannister army decimated on the
battlefield in season one guys skipped
over because ADA had the budget to show
that battle with green fork and this is
after Dorn's down the Greyjoy's have
pretty much been taking away his allies
and yet Tyrells a dog yeah so super
great to see a dragon in mid-battle you
know a fully-grown dragon was such an
exciting moment and then of course Jesse
reveals their plans to hai the golden
company yes then we got the dragon in
the wolf which you gotta go watch the
video to understand that was season 7
episode 7 Jon's confirmed to be the lead
Judah met Targaryen and he is a
legitimate Targaryen because basically
his parents secretly married yes so he
was previous marriage was annulled yeah
this one was minted and Gilly had a
purpose in that scene where she revealed
the information that she was casually
reading and then you've got the night
king bringing down the wall because he's
resurrected Vissarion aya kills
Littlefinger with up to the neck and
then John and Danny have stakes oh yeah
I mean basically auntie and nephew are
going for it but they don't know that
yet but Targaryen is with each other so
it's like really not weird but will it
be because this is only but it is weird
this is the second person John's been
with and the third person she's been
with so they're learning still
mm-hmm some big things like incest you
know it's it's interesting this list I
was looking through it I was reading the
plot summaries of each of these episodes
and it's like I it seems like cogman is
providing if you've never seen Game of
Thrones before if you're trying to get a
sense of the general like plot elements
to the show and like what what are the
big epic moments he kind of covers it
here I don't know if all of these plot
details are gonna be relevant in the
future yeah you know but let us know
what so Don this list you think was
missing is there any other essential
episodes like how can you watch Game of
Thrones without watching the episode
where
the chaos is a ladder episode that's
what's that included in there I'm not
really sure but we're gonna move on to
some other news that came out this week
a lot of information about Disney Plus
the streaming series that will take over
our lives the streaming service I should
say it it's gonna be released on
November 12th at a price of $6.99 per
month I believe $69 a year a year so a
little bit less than that if you do for
the full year they dropped a ton of info
about new shows shows that we kind of
knew about but they they gave us some
more details about it so we know the
Mandalorians coming out that's gonna be
a big one we had also talked on the show
about the Falcon and Winter Soldier
Series and Loki series cool that these
are all confirmed now yes they're all
all confirmed no longer rumored and then
we got a title for the vision Scarlet
Witch series which will be called Wanda
vision okay
and we got some details about the
what-if series that's gonna be like that
based on the Marvel comics or it's like
I've moved on from it I don't want to
sit in negativity anymore but let's talk
about this what if show because this
pilot that was announced sounds really
exciting to me the idea of it is what if
Peggy Carter took the Super Soldier
Serum instead of Captain America and
they said as a flip on it Steve Roger
stays like scrawny Oh
stick figure man but gets an armored
suit from Howard Stark that's awesome
and reminded this is animated so they
can get away with a lot like they don't
have to like do all the crazy visual
effects that they did on Chris Evans
they could just have a Peggy Carter turn
into she-hulk you know that and you
could maybe get the voice actors could
get it's confirmed that although what if
series will be the voice actor you'd
want to get him with Disney because
that's just a good paycheck every time
yes yes yes and if that was enough
excitement for one week we also learned
this wasn't at the Disney Plus panel but
we learned through other news sources
that they're playing the Hawkeye limited
series it'll star J me Renner and it'll
focus on him training Kate Bishop so I
was excited about this as they announced
at all these MCU should all these Marvel
shows are gonna tie into the MCU the
events are gonna be set in like a post
in-game world it's gonna be tough but if
anybody could pull it off it's going to
be Kevin
he and his team of you know geniuses and
it's gonna be considered canon the
events on the show there's been some
speculation that a Kate Bishop like
character could come in to play an
endgame or in phase four because yeah
they announced Katherine Langford would
be playing a role it's still unknown I
was like oh Katherine her name's Kate so
it must be Kate Bishop she could be
playing plenty of other characters like
Morgan's how people are cast based on
first name but this could be exciting we
could be seen like a live-action Kate
Bishop in the MCU and they could tie
into this new Hawkeye show mm-hmm it's
really cool but you know if it happens
to not be Catherine Langford who would
you like to see play Kate Bishop usually
the requirements are black hair we don't
know when New Mutants is coming I think
Maisie Millie Maisie Williams would be a
great choice she showed some great
archery skill on Game of Thrones that
could actually be pretty cool Marvel
actually I think she's a little mad
there you go exactly for me I like the
idea of a younger actress taking up the
role how I think every actress just
blanked out of my brain for a second
pretty good I mean honestly I know
sonses busy over at being a Phoenix yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna end soon though and
so well speaking of order of the Phoenix
and the x-men coming into MCU there's
some urgency news that came out this
week about that there is so go ahead and
click click what was that that was
buckling up because we've got an update
on a previous story from this week you
probably heard us talk a lot about the
Disney Foxx deal and all of the great
characters who are now be available to
join the MCU especially the x-men some
of us thought that would happen as early
as phase 4 but Kevin Feige decided to
crush some nerd dreams this week saying
it will be a very very very long time
and that the x-men are not a part of the
plan for the next 15 years no sorry 15
sorry 5 5 so I wanted to give everyone a
little bit of a rollercoaster so that's
why we had to buckle up I know right
flown right out on that windshield of
expectation so is there a chance that
they'll work in another Fox Marvel
character sooner than five years and
also is there a chance that he is a liar
that is a liar lying face liar lying
right to our poor little faces like
we're talking like maybe Fantastic Four
Deadpool you know there's plenty of the
other I think Fantastic Four is probably
if we're looking at heroes that will be
adapted in the story no they need time I
think I think they got I think time they
got time time are you mentioned is this
a are you trying to lead to Chronos
playing a role or Kang the Conqueror is
that over same time time Fantastic Four
is a good team to pull from if you
wanted some roof but it's some room
between the x-men movies the Fantastic
Four is a good it's a solid group of
characters that do have a fan base that
would be like in Marvel's hands it's
perfect it's a family you like to do
family stories you have ant-man's
basically all built on families and that
works really well and people actually
connect to that you made ant-man
possible as like as a standalone movie
character so all you got to do is add
two more people to that family and there
you go
Fantastic Four is a good job also doing
villain movie's wouldn't be the worst
idea either
you got Maleficent you're doing that
right now with Angelina Jolie yeah I
think it's more likely we'll see one of
the Fox Marvel villains play a role in
phase 4 then Mole Man before what phase
four could be known as since the
infinity saga is what the first three
phases have been called so we're talking
maybe the the Galactic or the Galactus
era you know he's such a huge villain
such an interesting character who really
wasn't done service by rights the Silver
Surfer and why well part various water
the fact they got afraid of a giant
antler helmeted villain eating planet so
they just made this weird space cloud
that didn't make any visual sense in the
movie I know it was kind of like fusses
cloud moment in the Lion King gone bad
hey guys remember when Olivia Munn
decided to like not play the girlfriend
in Deadpool because so she could be this
character psylocke I believe was cold in
x-men remember that that's all a big
mistake
you gotta think though after Days of
Future past things look great in the
x-men universe that movie was banned
stick all you have to do is ignore all
the horrible of rumors that you've heard
about the director of these movies and
keep working with him guys like the same
person in that movie then like anything
else that he's done that's just a mind
trick he's also fun on that one it's fun
to hear his interviews about that movie
he probably did not like it
Silver Surfer I feel like it's a good
character just to kind of grab if you're
not even if you didn't want to do
Fantastic Four first dealing with the
Silver Surfer would have been cool if
you wanted to do x-men in wand vision
may be talking about that sorry the logo
looks good one divisions like Google
glass like it's not great but III get
the idea of wanting to hop on the ship
named train first what are you like a
SModcast or something that's just like
we'll see i'm let's a quick bets on
post-credits scene for endgame if it's
gonna set up any of these characters for
phase 4 which one do you think it'll be
dead I'm gonna say Galactus I think like
this look like just wink okay go
going way big here mmm Miles Morales an
x-men character just to go will go big
with it or go with Silver Surfer or with
that like Galactus or something
celestial it's big it needs to be
something yeah and there you can deal
with the Celestials as well well let us
know what you are predicting to the end
game post credits scene and which of
these Fox Marvel characters you want to
see first in the MCU but before we
continue let's give a quick shout out to
one of our sponsors better help you may
have heard some stuff about better help
a while back but they've actually made
some really real solid changes and it's
an important service so let's give them
all another chance yeah is there
something that interferes with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
if so better help online counseling is
there for you better help offers
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression
stress anxiety relationships family
conflicts LGBT matters grief self-esteem
and more connect with your professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment anything you share is
confidential so and it's just very very
convenient and you can get help at your
own time and at your own pace and you
can schedule secure vid
or phone sessions plus chat and text
with your therapist which ever way is
easiest to do it for you
they have it and if you're not happy
with your counselor you can request a
new one at any time at no additional
charge but best of all it's a truly
affordable option and new rockstars
debrief listeners will get 10% off their
first month with a discount code
rockstars so why not get started today
you can just go to better help calm
slash rockstars simply fill out a
questionnaire and get matched with a
counselor that you will love better help
calm slash rockstars but let's move on
to some other news Sam that you were
talking about yes of course I'm already
buckled up I don't need to tell you guys
Aegis elbow will not be playing Deadshot
the character Will Smith played in the
previous film no no in this new James
Gunn's Suicide Squad reboot he will be
playing a brand-spanking-new character
give me some of that elbow you know I'm
saying just Lobo just a little bit
that's all where is good right we'll
need them to try to recreate a mr. fresh
no of course everyone's thinking Will
Smith in this movie if anyone remembers
that movie they want something new give
uh something new but we've already got
some news that Shazam sequels in the
works and most director and writer are
expected to return which is pretty
exciting the writer is a 100% all teams
go Davidov Sandberg please come back
according to Robert Pattinson and other
news is starring in Christopher Nolan's
next movie and he says it's the length
of three movies that is not a good
advertisement of miniseries yeah waited
way to give it a good sell Pattinson for
a little flick show but in the theater
yeah and what do you think of working
with one of the best directors in
Hollywood it's real balls pretty cheeky
waited like yeah I'm doing him with the
tone of what he said he must have been
if he sold he would drink
speaking of didn't find a segue Disney
released a new trailer for the hype
action Lion King
I try my best you guys did not give me
one word or
and twitter has a lot to say over the
new version of scars Twitter saying
about scars he's not pretty
yeah that's really what it is Lion King
trailer it's a bunch of gray things and
tan places sometimes episodes Walking
Dead this is because the lion Kings guy
was like Captain Hook as of Lion
really he had eyeliner and shadow and he
had like Terminator pink and green
highlights in there he had a beautiful
green eyes deep green you could let's go
is that what I'm what I'm getting from
you are getting that we all were
children no but not after we watch that
boot Michelangelo
hopefully he's in disliking and finally
estimates claim 1 billion people could
watch the final season of Game of
Thrones that's a lot Hospit so many
people a lot of those people won't
understand what they're saying because
there's not that many English speakers
and there might be a billion English
speakers in the world what am i some
titles you can know what is this sub of
the title yeah whoa but now comes the
time for her expertise lighting round
news
right now and the debrief of this one is
lightning round where you tweet us
questions we're gonna get some of them
on the screen up here I'm gonna fire
them at my co-host in an aggressive way
and they're gonna have to answer them as
quickly as possible
and without hesitation or I get crying
hey you guys ready Eric at 1 f j c o1
which character would you like to see
survive the game of friends but probably
warrant
tick tick Oh dick I want to survive I
don't think she will yeah die die she's
on my death will go to guess the throne
Sam and then you'll see my pool yeah
all right ask for seconds asks you if
the knight can hide by the way Mac if
the knight King were to speak only once
in the season 8 in season 8 what would
he say and to whom please answer what
you think his voice would sound like as
well we had to go through that Peter
teal are gonna break down brother that's
why I pushed you sometimes Sam because
we get stuff like that I'm going from at
me glad on 1989 what would you name your
dragon or direwolf quick faster faster
faster quick quick quick quick friend
and i said i EK i don't know i before E
except after shook and my that would be
my wolf my dragon goddamn I drag on when
I try and get this yesterday night
I just did was that for the pun not the
name um five years didn't say what the
animal is but change I want a letter
drogue on column Nitro because he's
makes fire Eddie's fast huh no well I
have to go through like a relative of
mine don't I any name now is not as cool
as nitro yeah I call my dragon Andrew
named after my father
yeah like that's cooler than Mike's
that's like calling a dog Kraig Oh pull
human names for a dog my dog's name is
Dwight and it's a good name yeah strong
names for everyone we have a question I
certainly do what what is your first
decree as you take your place on the
Iron Throne you are Eric first of the or
arabi okay this room at Efrain 79 I
would say democracy is now the law of
the land and we're not gonna have an
electoral college because that's a
bullsh baby would like to press a bit
number one he's probably bad in the news
right now
every waiver pokemon and they better
have it um like in the back of their
head they better know it better than
they know like the driver's license or
their kids names that's my first decree
as I'm or Jove House Garrett first in
her name under people that are 35 I
would like to make free healthcare
because as someone who's experienced it
guys you are behind yeah that is the
saddest damn thing yeah pokemon answer
was really cool though yeah thank you
thanks for all those questions folks now
comes the time for a 15-second shout out
each of us is 15 seconds to shout out
plug a ramble about anything
mmm I certainly do I am so proud of
myself I have a written all seven
seasons recap within a 10 minute space
but it's from my point of view of Game
of Thrones yes that's I should be up to
nap tomorrow on geek balm so head over
there subscribe to that one I'm super
proud of this video yeah because I wrote
it and I don't know how you do it Eric
it's it's tough writing is not fun I
would rather talk just one word in front
of the other you know it's not easy Sam
oh I'd go
/ - if you got a handy-dandy cellular
device going type in youtube.com / might
be awesome it's a news channel I do and
do little animated explainers of things
questions it's not what Eric does
promise it's different new to go check
it out please please it needs to do well
or my life will crumble huh Eric yeah
and and something else to check out I
want to shout out two videos that came
out recently on this channel neither of
which I hosted one was a Sam's breakdown
of the Joker trailer it was excellent
and us and Philip just did a video that
came out yesterday evening catching up
on everything you need to know about
Game of Thrones he doesn't his style and
both of these guys super funny yeah it's
it's I feel like they're very funny
they're very insightful and very well
edited and the reason I bring this up is
like yeah there's gonna be some times
videos come up on this channel which you
know it's not this dumb face that says
hi I'm Erik Bosse it's my friend
sometimes - but the doesn't mean that
like there's any kind of backstage
behind-the-scenes drama that you need to
read into like I wanted Sam do the Joker
birthday he did a great job of it he
knows and loves Joker I love that Philip
did this Game of Thrones video because
you know he knows game with her as well
as I do better and he's super funny and
and you can praise one of us and your
responses that on Twitter and in the
comments you can praise one of us
without insulting the other okay just a
reminder let's be civil I got some
pretty mean backhanded compliments on
Twitter and both times and it you know
when you tweet at us and you tag our
names in it we see it you know it's not
your - shouting this to the void so just
a reminder to be civil and that we're
all friends here and I love it when
other people are on this channel hosting
hate yourself more than tweeting out
hate to other people yes we shook heads
yeah we didn't get same that oh yes oh
it's fun now for the trivia answer let's
take a look again at that beautiful box
of Melissa made for us Wow how handsome
how handy how many questions gonna hold
millions all right answers as well so
gang it's time for the new punishment as
well let's go ahead and divvy these up I
got mom's answer right here uh-oh it's
wrong
I don't know I'm not sure but we reveal
the answers we've learned something
memory so short so our shame punishment
now the loser as decided by our judges
well no longer have to do a gift of
shame because we have a lot o do
listeners on the podcast so we want to
give them a way to enjoy us being
humiliated as well so the loser will
have to put one of these mouth things we
all do this much tit but it's from that
game what's it called something that's
the LAPD's version of this and then you
put this in your mouth and you're going
to talk for the rest of the episode with
your lips spread right open and you're
going to look and sound like a fool look
and sound so let's revisit this question
what was the working title of Star Wars
electric boogaloo first up Darth mod
said Blue Horizon which is the name of I
believe Jeff Bezos space program that
you could definitely correct me on that
but that is the name of something
there's some like working title named
blue Erik and this is direct quote Padme
has a hairpin in this movie
hairpin what a secret way to hide this
movie from the public she used a bobby
pin to move okay and then Sam said too
many cooks fight - well what's the
correct many cooks that's gonna be stuck
weak now
the answer is jar jar's great adventure
you're kidding
jar jar's great adventure what was the
working title of that's shower war see
who the Squeakquel what is now let's
look to our judges who is the closest
mod said Blue Horizon Eric's
said Padme has a hairpin in this movie
and Sam had the right answer so who got
it who was the furthest and who was
closest you have a Star Wars character
in that is do we have a most loser I
like mine has a to win my oh that's fine
I actually wanted to use one so Sam's
going to be our first joiner of this
shame did you enjoy this episode of new
rock stars new debrief what's your
favorite part of this episode right here
part of this sodium is our own Disney
Disney though the plus sign that's fun
dizzy Plus that's not I just clicked oh
dude our goodbyes
to say thank you to our host Sam yeah
sure yeah sure
and Garrett that's Garrett also edit and
you can get it earth places the videos
you feel that confess new rock stars and
you could get the audio podcasts you can
be like if you use the hair layer and
it's loose show directly and treat at
the New York stars like this you you I
was starting to sound like the the
priest in Princess Bride just like mr.
Rogers says at the end the he shall say
Aaron say crying crying dying